marie guillemard sociologue professeur
émérite à l'université paris descartes
sorbonne expert en conseil d'orientation
des retraites bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france on vient de le voir
un sacré défi 12 milliards à trouver en
trois mois edouard philippe piat bon
espoir d'un compromis à l'issue de cette
conférence vous partager son optimisme
et au premier ministre
non pas du tout pas du tout je crois que
ça va être très difficile mais surtout
moi je m'interroge sur ce qu'est devenue
cette réforme qu est ce qui reste de la
réforme de 2010 est proposé par le
candidat macro et justement vous n'étiez
pas c'est important de le préciser vous
n'étiez pas farouchement opposée vous
étiez plutôt d'accord avec cette réforme
je veux des points très positifs que je
peux rappeler l essonne meaux
voilà vous fera du bien à la mémoire le
projet je le redis c'était une réforme
systémique et non pas paramétrique donc
plus de mesures d'âge s'était annoncée
comme telle
le projet c'était de trouver de
reconstruire une assurance vieillesse du
21e siècle où les mots ou la mobilité
professionnelle les parcours
professionnels sont devenus très mobiles
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
et salariés qui liquident leur retraite
ont au moins trois régimes et demi et
donc des règles différentes etc et ça
devient illisible et très bientôt cinq
régimes
donc on imagine qu'on ne peut pas
calculer ces retraites or l'idée de la
femme deuxième point important et c'est
c'est que pour rendre transparent le
calcul de la retraite le simplifier et
gérable par les individus ça pète ça
leur permet de choisir le moment
opportun c'est à dire que l'idée c'était
d'avoir 62 ans comme h plancher pour
liquider sa retraite et à partir de là
vous choisissez donc c'est ce que la
cfdt a appelé la retraite à la carte
on part soit 62 ans
si on estime que l' on a moins de
retraite mois une pension retraite à 62
que si on attend plus longtemps puisque
il ya une incitation à prolonger
l'activité
donc ça c'était les points positifs mais
moi je ne les vois plus parce qu'on est
devenu on est rentré à nouveau dans une
réforme paramétrique comme on en a eu
toute une série depuis 2003 pas moins de
cette réforme quand même depuis 2003 et
tout paramétrique et que le cui lé wifi
et donc les mesures d'âge se réinstalle
comme comme élément central de la
négociation
et oui pourquoi faut-il faire des
économies alors que l'idée et c'est ce
que disait jean-paul delvoye pour une
fois en france on fait une réforme à
coût constant 14% du pime l'effort
français était selon le cor conseil
d'orientation des retraites 14% du pipe
jusqu'en 2070 vers le même corps qui
nous expliquait aussi que n'explique pas
voilà les indices à 17 milliards de
déficit mais ça c'est télé c'est parce
que on souligne ça alors on a beaucoup
sonné servir il faut voir ici potez
justement mais on est serrés attention
c'est une commande de gouvets
moment oui oui non mais je sais bien des
hypothèses derrière et s'il ya un
déficit c'est parce que l'état se retire
et veut se retirer et que l'état réduit
le nombre de fonctionnaires donc ça fait
des cotisants en moins donc c'est tout
lié à l'état et à ses projets ce n'est
pas le déficit l'un ton qu'on nous fait
croire que c'est les déficits
ce n'est pas le déficit c'est que l'état
veut changer son mode de financement des
retraites
soyez plus précises parce que c'est
intéressant justement quand on vous dit
l'état veut changer à changer de
stratégie puisque vous l'avez répéter ce
n'était pas du tout dans le programmes
des manuels micron au départ
effectivement il avait bien dit qu'il
réformerait les retraites le système
universel à point mais pas de question
de mesures d'âge selon vous donc il ya
eu une stratégie qui est venu par la
suite
oui quelles raisons c'est darmanin
philippe au moment de pâques à peu près
qui ont sorti cette histoire de mesures
d'âge avec donc une raison un peu caché
vous nous dites clairement mais je pense
financière parce que et là de plus en
plus le le le le déficit est devenu au
score or que précisément dans le projet
de réforme et j'ai entendu maintes
reprises
jean-paul delvoye le dire pour une fois
on fait à coût constant
et puis tout d'un coup il ya des
déficits peut-être oui mais et ça a été
un rapport spécial mais qui est lu
unilatéralement par le gouvernement il
prend les cas c'est pas du tout ce que
dit le corps
si on le lit ligne à ligne si on regarde
les hypothèses qui ont été faites les
hypothèses fait présenter dans le corps
je n'ai pas pris mes papiers ayant
mérité ce que c'est par le corps
ne sont pas tellement dramatique il ya
très peu de choses sur certaines
hypothèses il n'y a rien du tout les 17
milliards c'est dans le cas où
effectivement l'état se retire supprime
beaucoup de postes de fonctionnaires etc
aujourd'hui vous avez bon espoir quand
même que cette mesure d'âge d' équilibre
nous dit-on soit retirée sous la
pression de la cfdt qui les ont bon
espoir
j'ai pas bons espoirs c'était un des
seuls manifestement il ya une reprise en
main et est une vision uniquement
comptable et j'en suis désolé non moi je
suis même presque en colère parce que je
trouvais que c'était un beau projet que
de que d'actualiser l'assurance
vieillesse au 21e siècle avec ce qui se
fait en finlande ce qui se fait en sus
elle ce qui est déjà été fait c'est à
dire 1 h plancher et après la
possibilité pour les gens contenu leur
situation il ya des gens qui sont en
mauvaise santé qui veulent partir le
plus tôt possible
il ya d'autres qui ont des enfants
encore la parentalité tardive s'est
répandue donc il ya d'autres qui ont des
responsabilités parentales encore
impliquante qui veulent continuer parce
qu'ils veulent pas être retraité tout de
suite donc les si vous voulez les
mesures d'âge elles sont injustes
d'abord parce que hein on ne gouverne
plus aujourd'hui lèvres les populations
par des mesures d'âge car à un même âge
les gens sont différents aujourd'hui
vous à dépendre leur parcours
professionnel
ça dépend de leur situation familiale
donc ils sont différents à 50 ans un
homme peut être en parentalité à redire
un autre peut être avec des enfants déjà
installés c'est in auront pas la même
stratégie pour prendre leur retraite
donc l'argument très rapidement puisque
c'est terminé me dit-on au moment où je
pose ma question l'argument de justice
sociale vantée par le gouvernement ça
aussi la route et là ce n'est plus de la
justice et de l'injustice qui va
travailler plus longtemps si on met la
lâche pivot ce sont les ouvriers quand
comment ces jeunes toutes mesures d'âge
est injuste et elle elle frappe les
ouvriers c'était le cas dans la réforme
sarkozy de 2010 merci beaucoup madame
anne marie guillemard d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre analyse merci à
vous